This is Foundations
of Osteopathic
Medicine lecture
on head and neck
embryology, given
by Dr. Aki Watanabe.
Just like my
previous lecture on
introduction to
the head and neck,
the same rules
apply for my slides.
So any red text on
slides mean that
they're fair game
for the exam,
as well as anatomical
structures that are
labeled either in red
or in red highlight.
and make sure to
pay attention to
any of the
clinical correlates
that I go over
during my lectures.
And finally, I highly
recommend going over
the learning objectives
that I list in the
course preparation
guide for this lecture,
which will give you the
topics you should focus
on when studying for
the lecture content.
So here's a video
showing the remarkable
changes that happen
in the head and
neck during development.
So this is about
a 30-second clip that
goes to the journey
of four to five
-week-old embryo to
14 weeks. So this is
showing the changes
that's happening in
the head and neck
during essentially
the first trimester.
So during the lecture,
we'll be talking
about some of the
processes that are
involved in this
incredible transformation.
So in the first part
of this lecture,
we'll talk about the
segmented structures
in the head and
neck. And then in the
second part, we'll
talk about the rebels
that go against these
segmented regions.
And then the third
and the last part,
we'll talk about the
germ layer contributions
to the head and
neck structures.
So these include
the ectoderm,
endoderm, mesoderm,
and neurocrestal
derivatives that
exist in the head.
So let's start talking
about segmented
structures.
And so if you
look at somebody's
head or face, it's
hard to figure
out any segmented
structures.
But if you look at
the postcranium,
you do see some segmented
structures, as you
talked about probably
in previous
embryology lectures.
For example, when
you pay attention to
the vertebrae and the
ribs, you can clearly
see segmented
structures and system of
organization that
happens in the body.
So what about the head?
Well, in order to
look at segments
that occur in
the head, we need
to pay attention
to early embryos.
So when you look at
the top row, which
shows embryos around
four to five weeks
across different
animals, do you see any
segmented structures
around the head?
Here they are. And
you might have seen
these knobs that are
coming off of the neck
of the embryo. So
there are four to six
pharyngeal arches that
exist in early embryos
of different animals.
In humans, there
are four that are very
visible but they're
actually six pharyngeal
arches in the
beginning but we understand
a little bit about
the fifth arch which
tends to disappear
and then the fourth is
very closely related
to six so you can
consider them four and
six arches to be together
so in total there
are four visible
pharyngeal arches on the
external surface of
the embryo and these
are called pharyngeal
or brachial arches.
Here at the center
of the slide,
you see a cross-sectional
image of an embryo,
which is cut
basically where the
blue line is on this
top right inset
image. And so we're
looking down from the
top of this embryo.
And you'll notice
that pharyngeal
arches are just
part of this
larger pharyngeal
apparatus.
So arches are
the evaginated
segments of the ectoderm.
And there are pharyngeal
clefts that represent
the invagination of
the ectoderm, and
they exist between two
adjacent pharyngeal
arches. Similarly,
there's the pharyngeal
pouch, which is the
invagination of the endoderm
that's within the
embryo. And then between
the cleft and the
pouch is the pharyngeal
membrane. And these
are numbered from
cranial to caudal
direction. So the first arch
will have pharyngeal
arch one, and then
posterior to that will
be the pharyngeal cleft
one and pharyngeal
pouch one over here,
and then pharyngeal
membrane one in between.
what's important to
know is that these
pharyngeal apparatus
and these segments are
all associated for
with four derivative
structures so these
include bones and
cartilage arteries
cranial nerves and muscles
so where do the
pharyngeal apparatus go
in adults well when
you look at fish
and sharks for example
on the left, the
structures that
derive from pharyngeal
arches and pharyngeal
apparatus is associated
with these gills
that you see on
the sides of the head
and neck in fishes
and sharks. So they're
organs that are
involved with
respiration and feeding.
And in non-fish animals,
for example, other
mammals and birds, for
example, and lizards,
we obviously don't
have gills. but
the structures that
are derived from these
pharyngeal apparatus
are still involved
heavily with feeding
and respiration
and humans actually
have co-opted these
derivative structures
as facial muscles and
vocalizations adding
more functionality
to the structures
that come from these
pharyngeal arches.
So in previous
embryology lectures you
learned about
somites which are
packets of mesoderms
that you can see
lined up along the
anterior to posterior
axis or the body
axis of an embryo.
In the head, there are
similar structures,
but these are
called somitomeres.
And these are
units of mesoderm
in the head, but
compared to somites
that you see
them distinctly,
the distinction
is not as clear in
somitomeres. So they're
not as separated,
which you can see
of this image below.
And you can see
that the somitomeres
are responsible
for creating
mesodermal structures
in the head and
the neck. So let's
start with on the
anterior side.
So the first few
somitomeres will be used
to create extraocular
muscles. So
these are muscles
that are responsible
for eye movement.
And the more posterior
somitomeres will be
responsible for going
into the pharyngeal
arches to make mesodermal
structures, especially
the muscles that
are associated with
these pharyngeal arches.
And what's neat is
that the tongue, although
this is a structure
that exists in the
head, they are created
from mesodermal packets,
the somites, from
more posterior part of
the body. And this is
why the innervation of
the tongue, the motor
innervation, I should
say, is coming from
the most posterior
cranial nerve, which is
cranial nerve 12, or
the hypoglossal nerve.
And the arteries
are also originally
very segmented
in embryos.
So you have the
arches, and you can see
on the left in this
oblique view of an
embryo that there are
clearly defined arteries
that are based on
these pharyngeal
arches. But during
development, arches one,
two, and five mostly
disappear, and the
other arches change
shape. So the segmented
starting point
for these arteries
become kind of lost.
So you don't really
see these segmented
structures or
organizations when
you look at arteries
of a baby and
adults and humans.
So now, as with
the cranial nerves
that I went over
in my introduction
to head and neck lecture,
I recommend creating
another table
to organize the
derivatives coming
off of the
pharyngeal apparatus.
So on the leftmost
column, you can have
the arches. So arch
number one, two, three,
and then you can
put the four and six
together. And remember
that five is missing
and disappears during
development. it.
So the first arch
is also called the
mandibular arch. The
second is also called
hyoid arch. Third is
also called carotid.
Fourth and sixth are
called systemic and
pulmonary arches
respectively. And as I
mentioned before,
each of these arches
are associated with
bone and cartilage
structures, muscles,
arteries, and cranial
nerves. And after
I've gone through the
pharyngeal arch
derivatives, I'll also go
over the derivatives
coming off of the
pharyngeal pouches,
clefts, and membranes.
So just like bingo,
you get some free
space. So actually,
you can block
out two of the
spaces. So arch number
one and two do
not contribute
significantly to
any of the arteries.
so let's start with
the pharyngeal arch
one also called the
mandibular arch so the
cartilaginous and
bony derivatives of
the mandibular arch
includes the cartilaginous
precursor of the
bony mandible this
is also called meccal's
cartilage and so
the pharyngeal arch
one does not directly
create the bony
mandible but rather it
creates the cartilaginous
scaffold that will
help the bony mandible
form around it.
It also is responsible
for creating the
malleus and incus
bones. And so these
are the hammer-like
bone and the incus or
the anvil-shaped bone.
And these are tiny
bones in the middle
ear, and these help
amplify sound so
you can hear better.
And so you might be
wondering, well, this
is a mandibular arch,
so it must be related
to the lower jaw. So
why are bones that are
inside of your ear
associated with this
arch? Well, there's a
neat evolutionary story
here. And that's
because the malleus and
the incus bones used
to be jaw bones in more
primitive and ancestral
mammals. And you
see this in other non
-mammalian animals as
well. So when you take
a look at fossils of
mammal ancestors, you
see that the quadrate
and articular have
become decoupled from
the jaws and they have
slowly moved in to
the middle ear and this
transition evolutionary
transition could be
seen by looking at
a series of fossils
going from the most
primitive mammals or
mammal relative all the
way to modern mammals
which is a neat story.
And that's why the
malleus and incus are
the derivatives of
pharyngeal arch one.
So now let's talk
about the arterial
derivatives. Well,
actually, I told
you this is one of
the free spaces.
And although the
arch one contributes
to parts of the
maxillary artery and
external carotid
artery, it's too
significant to be
included in the table.
So no need to know
that for the exam.
In terms of the muscle
derivatives, you
have muscles of
mastication or also known
as jaw muscles. So
these are muscles
responsible for opening
and closing your
jaw for chewing. So
these include the
temporalis muscle,
masseter muscle, and the
pterygoids. You also
have several other
muscles. So tensor
tympani, which tenses
the tympanic membrane
or the eardrum,
tensor villi palatini,
an anterior belly of
the digastric muscle,
and then myelohyoid.
and what is the cranial
nerve associated
with these
muscles? Well, it's
cranial nerve five
or the trigeminal.
Now we'll move on to
pharyngeal arch two,
also known as
hired arch and the
cartilaginous and bony
structures that derive
from pharyngeal arch
two includes the
stapes bone, which
is the third middle
ear ossicles, and the
stylo process, which
the stylofaryngous
muscle attaches to.
And then you
have the hyoid or
parts of the hyoid,
including the
lesser horn and
the upper body.
And again, this is one of
the free spaces
for arteries.
So you don't need
to know for the
exam, but it
forms part of the
stapedio arteries
and embryos, but
that disappears
during development.
And then in
terms of muscles,
the pharyngeal arch 2
creates the
muscles of facial
expression, the
stapedius muscle that
holds on to the
stapes, and the
posterior belly
of the digastric.
And so what nerve
is responsible
for facial
expression muscles?
Well, it's the cranial
nerve 7 or the
facial nerve.
moving forward now
we're on to pharyngeal
arch 3 also known
as the carotid
arch and the cartilaginous
and bone structure
that derives from
it include the hyoid
and parts of the hyoid
which is the greater
horn and the lower
body so both the
pharyngeal arch 2 and 3
contribute to the formation
of the hyoid but
different parts of it
In terms of arteries,
it creates the
internal and external
carotid arteries.
And for muscles, it
leads to the creation of
stylopharyngous muscles.
And then the cranial
nerve that innervates
this muscle is the
glossopharyngeal nerve
or cranial nerve nine.
And it also makes
sense when you think
about what we learned
in my previous lecture,
where the carotid body
and the carotid sinus
is innervated by the
glossopharyngeal nerve.
Let's move on to
pharyngeal arch number
four also known as
systemic arch and the
cartilaginous and
bony structure here
includes the laryngeal
cartilages except for
the epiglottis and so
this is formed together
with the pharyngeal
arch number six.
In terms of arteries
it forms parts of
the aorta and the
right subclavian artery
And so what about
the left subclavian?
Well, that's formed
from what's considered
seventh arch, but it's
not discussed here
any further because
it's a very poorly
known arch in the
pharyngeal apparatus.
And in terms of
the muscles, it's
responsible for
creating the
cricothyroid, levator
veli palatini,
constrictors of the
pharynx, and the
strident muscles
of the esophagus.
And these muscles
are associated with
the vagus nerve,
which is cranial nerve
10. And pharyngeal
arch 4 actually
is responsible for
the superior laryngeal
branch or the
nerve of the vagus.
Now, the pharyngeal
arch six, also known
as pulmonary arch,
again, just like
what I've shown
you in the previous
slide, together with
pharyngeal arch four,
it's responsible
for the laryngeal
cartilages, except
for the epiglottis.
And it forms part of
the pulmonary arteries.
And in terms of
the muscles, it's
responsible for the
intrinsic laryngeal muscles.
that's actually,
it's one of its
functions is to allow
me to talk like this.
And the nerve that's
responsible for
that is the vagus
nerve, specifically
the recurrent
laryngeal nerve.
And so this is a
nice diagram that
summarizes the key
structures that are
derived from each
laryngeal arch, which
are color-coded by
the arch number.
And it doesn't include
arteries, but it
shows a lot of the
other derivatives.
So just to recap,
ARCH1 is responsible
for the meccalus
cartilage, which is that
cartilaginous precursor
to the lower jaw.
And also is responsible
for the malleus
and incus.
And those are the bony
and the cartilaginous
structures. and it's
also associated with
cranial nerve five or
trigeminal nerve that
innervates the jaw
muscles and several
other muscles as well
including the temporalis
muscle and the
masseter muscle and the
anterior body belly of
the digastric muscle.
Arch two is responsible
for the styloid
process, the stapes
which is another
ear bone and part of
the hyoid specifically
the lesser horn
and the upper body.
And it is associated
cranial nerve seven
that innervates the
muscles, the facial
expression, and
several others as well.
Arch three in blue,
the cartilage in
this arch forms
part of the hyoid,
more specifically
the greater horn of
the higher bone
in the lower body.
And the cranial nerve 9,
or the glossopharyngeal
nerve, is the one
that innervates the
stylopharyngeus muscle,
which is misspelled
on this image. It
should be STY, not STI.
And finally,
we have ARCH4.
And the cartilage
that forms from ARCH4
includes the thyroid
and cricoid cartilages,
so part of the laryngeal
cartilages, and it's
associated with the
vagus nerve, is more
specifically the
superior laryngeal nerve.
And this innervates
the pharyngeal muscles.
This is another
diagram that organizes
the structures by
anatomical systems, so by
nerves, muscles, and
cartilage in bone.
So once again,
arch one is
associated with
trigeminal nerve,
arch two with
the facial nerve,
arch three with the
glossopharyngeal
nerve, and arch
four and six
are both associated
with the vagus.
In terms of muscles,
arch one is associated
with muscles of
mastication or the
jaw opening and
closing muscles and
other muscles. Arch
two with muscles of
the facial expression
and several others.
Arch three with
the stylopharyngeus
muscle and arch four
and six with the
muscles of the larynx
and the esophagus.
In terms of
cartilaginous and bony
structures, Arch one
is associated with
mandible, malleus,
and incus. Arch
two with the hyoid,
the upper portion,
stapes, and the styler
process. Arch three
with the hyoid and
the lower portion of
the hyoid. And then
arch four and six are
associated with the
laryngeal cartilagous.
so we covered the
derivatives of the pharyngeal
arches and so now
we're ready to move
into the derivatives
of the other parts of
the pharyngeal
apparatus which includes
the cleft pouches and
the membranes and just
to help out with the
visualization recall
that the pouch is the
invagination of the
endoderm so what
that looks like three
-dimensionally so this
is a high this is a side
view of an embryo where
the pharyngeal arch
and membrane have
been removed so this
the gray is endodermal
layer and you can see
the out pocketings
of the endoderm layer
and this is what causes
the pouches to form
what makes it easier
to study is that of
the clefts and membranes
one through four
only the first one
contributes to adult
structures so you have
the pharyngeal cleft
here that becomes the
external auditory meatus.
And then the
pharyngeal membrane one
becomes a tympanic
membrane or your eardrum.
And so clefts and
membranes two, three, and
four do not contribute
to any adult structures,
which keeps it
simple. So in fact,
clefts two, three, and
four becomes invaginated
and joined together to
make a larger sinus,
the cervical sinus, which
becomes obliterated.
But when it doesn't,
it can lead to
fistula and cysts, which
we'll talk about in
our clinical call
section in a little bit.
So let's start with
pharyngeal pouch
cleft and membrane
derivatives from the
first pouch cleft
and membranes. And so
cleft one becomes
external auditory meatus,
and membrane one
becomes a tympanic
membrane or the
eardrum, which we just
covered. And then
pouch one becomes the
tympanic cavity plus
the eustachian tube
that's going to lead
into the nasopharynx.
Pharyngeal pouch
two, since we don't
have to worry about
the cleft or the
membrane, is that
pouch two becomes the
palatine tonsils. And
so tonsils are masses
of lymphoid tissue
and it traps
bacteria and viruses
entering the oral
cavity. And it also
produces antibodies to
help protect them
from the infection.
Now let's talk about
pharyngeal pouches
three and four and the
derivatives. You can
package pouch three and
four together because
their derivatives
consist of glandular
tissue that exists in
the deep neck that we
talked about in the
previous lecture. So
in the pouch three, the
cranial portion gives
rise to the inferior
parathyroid gland,
and the caudal portion
becomes the thymus.
And pouch four, the
cranial portion becomes
the superior hair
thyroid gland, and
then the caudal portion
becomes what's called
the ultimobranchial
body, which is
misspelled here. It's
missing an N in this
illustration,
ultimobranchial body. and it
gives rise to
parafollicular, also called
C-cells, and these
cells secrete calcitonin
and calcitonin acts
to reduce calcium
in the blood. So
it's another way of
controlling the level
of calcium in the body.
Now let's talk about
clinical correlates.
And so this is about
the brachial fistula
and cysts. So this
is pretty rare,
but it's good to know
what is caused by
that cervical cyst
remaining throughout
development. So normally
the cervical cyst
formed from pouches
two through four
gets obliterated, but
if they remain and
if there is an opening
into the external
environment, you
end up with openings
occurring along the
anterior margin of the
sternocleidomastoid
muscle, which you
can see on a patient
on the right here.
On the other hand, if
the cervical cyst has
an opening internally,
then it typically
follows the location
of the patine tonsils.
So you'll see an opening
inside of the mouth
at the location of
the patine tonsils. So
this is an illustration,
a drawing that
shows kind of a three
-dimensional configuration
of the pouches and
the derivatives, which
might help you
visualize and understand
the derivatives and
their relative locations,
a little bit better
than flat images.
So we have the first
pharyngeal pouch here
that becomes the
internal eustachian tube
and the middle ear or
the tympanic cavity.
You have the second
pharyngeal pouch that
becomes the site of
the palatine tonsils.
And then moving on to
the third pharyngeal
pouch, the cranial
portion becomes the
inferior parathyroid
gland, and then the
caudal portion becomes
the thymus. And then
finally, the pharyngeal
pouch forward, the
cranial portion
becomes the
superior parathyroid
gland, and the
caudal portion becomes
the ultimobranchial body.
Now that we're
done with the first
part of this
lecture, we're
ready for an example
exam question.
So a toddler has a
hearing defect. MRI
scans show that
the toddler has
developmental defects
in auditory or the
eustachian tube and
the tympanic cavity.
Which pharyngeal
apparatus component
mostly likely developed
abnormally? The
answer here is B,
pharyngeal pouch 1.
The derivatives
of pharyngeal
pouch 1 include
the tympanic
cavity and the
eustachian tube.
This is part two
of the FOM lecture
on head and
neck embryology.
This is going to
be on structures
that deviate from the
segmented pharyngeal
structures.
We'll start off
with the tongue.
So tongue
development traverses
multiple pharyngeal
arches, hence
why they have
complex innervations.
So when you look at
the figure up the
top row, you see
that pharyngeal
arch 1 extends as it
grows and forms the
anterior two-thirds
of the tongue.
When you look at
arch 2, you see that
arch 3 begins to
overgrow over arch
2. So arch 2 essentially
disappears, at
least from the
external surface of
the tongue, but
still provides taste
innervation to the
anterior two-thirds.
And arch 3 and 4
form the mucosa of
the posterior one
-third of the tongue.
and tongue muscles
that form and are
underlying these
external surfaces in the
mucosa are formed from
the occipital somites
which I mentioned
towards the beginning
of this lecture and
that's why cranial
nerve 12 provides
the motor innervation
which is the caudal
most cranial nerve
and this makes
sense when you think
about the complex
sensory innervation
to the tongue so So
anterior two-thirds,
the somatic sensory
innervation is
provided by cranial
nerve 5, which
is associated with
pharyngeal arch 1.
And then the
taste for anterior
two-thirds of the
tongue is provided
by cranial nerve
7, or facial.
And then pharyngeal
arch 3 provides the
mucosal and the taste
innervation for the
posterior one-third of
the tongue. And that's
why both the somatic
sensory and the special
taste sensory innervation
is provided by the
glossopharyngeal nerve
for the posterior
one-third of the tongue.
And then even more
posterior to that,
both the taste and the
somatic sensory
innervation is provided by
the vagus nerve, which
comes from arch four.
Next up is thyroid.
thyroid and thyroid
originates from the
single outpouching of
endoderm shown here on
the ventral side between
arches one and two
and this is called
the thyroid diverticulum
and diverticulum
just means an outpocketing
and this exists
if you go back one slide
at the foramen cecum
which is between the
area of the tongue
that's formed by arch
one and arch three.
Now let's talk about
thyroid development.
So the thyroid originates
from the single
outpocketing on the
endoderm on the ventral
side between arches
one and two. So if you
go back one slide, you
can see this foramen
cecum that exists
between the area of the
tongue formed by arch
one and arch three.
and so remember that
diverticulum means
outpocketing so this is
just a small outpocketing
that will eventually
become the thyroid
gland and during
development as the
embryo and the tongue
grow the developing
thyroid gland descends
down the neck so it
starts out as a thyroid
primordium or the
diverticulum but it
starts to descend through
the neck passing
through the developing
higher bone and laryngeal
cartilages. And as
it goes down, it
generates or produces this
narrow duct called
a thyroglossal duct.
And as it continues
or the thyroid
gland continues
downward, it's
going to create a
longer thyroglossal
duct along the
midline anterior
side of the neck and
after a while the
thyroglossal duct
degenerates and then
what only what
remains is the opening
pit of the thyroglossal
duct called the
foramen cecum which
we saw on one of the
previous slides and
this figure shows
the pathway that the
thyroglossal duct
took towards the
thyroid gland.
So clinical correlate
related to the
thyroglossal duct is what
happens when this duct
does not close up
or does not get
obliterated. That will
lead to the thyroglossal
duct sinus or thyroglossal
duct cyst. And
the difference between
the two is that
thyroduct cyst, let's
start with there in the
middle of the slide,
is there will be a
cavity or cyst that
remains because the
thyroglossal duct did
not seal up properly.
On the other hand,
thyroglossal duct cyst
forms, or excuse me,
thyroglossal duct
sinus forms when
there's an opening to
an external environment.
And both the cyst
and sinus pose a risk
because infection
can start and spread
within the cyst.
So keep in mind that
thyroglossal duct
cyst forms along
the midline of the
neck, not lateral like
the branchial cysts.
So make sure that
you pay attention
to the location of
this opening to decide
whether it is due
to the thyroglossal
duct cyst or sinus
or branchial cyst.
The third clinical
correlate related to the
thyroid gland and the
thyroglossal duct is
an ectopic thyroid
gland. And this is fairly
common. And the most
common presence or
presentation of this is
the pyramidal lobe, which
is a little extension
along the midline of
the thyroid gland so
the thyroid gland is
usually h-shaped but
sometimes you'll see
this extension along the
midline pointing upwards
and this is called
the pyramidal lobe and
this is just the thyroid
gland growing along
just the short end portion
of the phyroglossal
duct and this is not
this does not pose
any risk to someone's
health and you might
see it on your cadaver
in the anatomy lab.
Another special
developmental process that
occurs in the head
is called placodes.
And so placodes are
ectodermal discs that
form from this thin
ectodermal layer. So when
the ectodermal layer
during development
invaginates, so again
forming and in-pocketing
and buds off, as you
can see on this lower
left-hand corner,
then it forms what's
called a placode. And
there are a number of
special sensory structures
that are derived
from placodes. So
these include the nasal
placode, which will
form the mucosa of the
nasal cavity. So that's
going to be closely
associated with the sense
of smell or olfaction.
The lens placode,
which forms the lens
of the eye, the otic
placode, which forms
the vestibule and
cochlea of the inner ear,
and it also forms
neurogenic placoids,
which forms parts of
the cranial nerves.
So as I mentioned,
these placodes tend
to be associated
closely with cranial
nerves and especially
special sensory nerves.
So nasal placode
is associated with
cranial nerve one or
the olfactory nerve.
Lens placode is
closely associated with
the optic nerve.
and the otic placode
is closely
associated with the
vestibulocochlear nerve
or cranial nerve eight.
Now let's talk about the
development of the face.
So the facial primordia
or the precursor to
the face begins with
three major regions. So
you have the frontal
nasal prominence here
and you have the
maxillary prominences just
above the stomodium
or the embryonic mouth
and then the mandibular
prominences and these
three major regions will
differentiate further
so at six weeks old
the frontal nasal
prominence will divide
into sort of the frontal
area and then the
nasal process over here
on each side of the
embryonic face so on the
lateral side this lateral
nasal process will
eventually form the
sides of the nose which
you can kind of follow
along in the seven
and eight weak embryos.
And then the medial
nasal process will come
together to form the
intermaxillary segment
shown here in yellow.
And this will form
the nasal septum, the
middle part of the upper
lip and the philtrum
or the medial cleft,
which you can see
here on the lower right
part of the image.
and then the
left and right
maxillary prominences
will come meet
the intermaxillary
prominences
to form the upper
cheek regions and
the upper lip shown
here in blue and
then the left and
right mandibular
prominences will
form the lower jaw
lower lip and the
lower cheek regions
so now let's take
the video that we saw
at the very beginning
of this lecture
and just go over
what we just learned.
So here we have the
frontal nasal prominence,
and you have the
nasal process forming
here. You have the
maxillary process here,
and then you have the
mandibular process
over here. And here
are the lateral and
the medial portion of
the nasal processes,
which is going
to meet to form
the intermaxillary
process.
And then those will
further develop and
differentiate to form
the face of a fetus.
So there's a
clinical correlate
associated with the
formation of the
face as well as
the hard palate.
So the palate forms
through two stages.
So we have the primary
palate, which is
formed from the extension
of the intermaxillary
segment. So this was
the yellow portion
that we also saw
in two slides ago
before we played the
video. And this will
form what's called,
again, the primary palate,
if you follow it
to the right of the
image. The secondary
pallet forms from
joining of the pallet
time process coming from
the maxillary
prominences in blue here.
So in this view,
we're looking
at the embryo
bottom up. So
we're looking up
at the pallet.
And by the end, both
of these pallets will
close up, forming a
unified hard pallet.
So the clinical
correlate portion comes
when there is incomplete
fusion enclosure of
the maxilla and your
palate. And this is
actually pretty common.
So occurs in about
one in 1000 births.
And the cleft lip
originates from incomplete
fusion around the
lip between the
intermaxillary segment and
the palatine process.
and the more severe
version is the cleft
palate where you have
opening within the
hard palate due to the
incomplete fusion of
the path time process
on both sides as well
as the primary palate
formed from the
intermaxillary segment.
So this results in
abnormal facial appearance
and defective speech
and nowadays it can
be treated in most cases
and involves surgery
and any therapies,
for example, speech
therapies to improve
associated conditions.
So when you have a
cleft palate, it means
that the oral and nasal
cavities are connected.
So that definitely
needs to be treated in
order to prevent issues
with, for example,
feeding.
Now let's talk about
skull development.
So I'm going to
go through this
briefly, and you do
not need to know the
details as on this
slide for the exam.
So you have three
embryonic components
that make up the
skull. So you have the
chondrocranium,
which is formed from
endochondral bones, so
bones that start off as
cartilage and then
transforms into bone.
So these include the
occipital, sphenoid,
ethmoid, and
temporal bones, at
least the petrous
or the hard part
where the middle and
inner ear resides.
You also have the
desmocranium, which is
the membranous bone
to the sides and tops
of the brain case,
forms the calvary.
And these include
the frontal,
occipital, and
the parietal.
Although this is shown
in blue, parts of
it should be membranous
bone in purple.
You also have
viscerocranium, which is
derived from pharyngeal
arches via, again,
membranous ossification.
So these include
the temporal bone, the
squamous part, or the
flat part, maxillabone,
zygomatic, and
the mandible bone,
shown here in the image.
Brain development,
similarly, you
don't need to know
anything on this
slide, but just wanted
to let you know
that the neural
tube, which you
should have gone over
in one of the first
embryo lectures,
becomes more differentiated
into the forebrain,
midbrain, and hindbrain,
and these will
further differentiate
into different
subdivisions of the
brain. You will cover
neuronality in more
detail next semester. But
the reason why I went
over the skull and brain
development, even
if it briefly, is to
talk about some important
clinical correlates
that is caused by
deviations from this
coordinated development
of the brain and skull
they have to develop
together but what if
it doesn't so one of
the conditions that
could occur is called
craniosynostosis and
this is deformity of
the skull due to the
********* closure of
the sutures which means
that the fontanelle is
closed too early and
so the type of defect
and the deformation
depends on which suture
closed prematurely.
Microcephaly is having
a smaller brain. It's
caused by abnormal
development of the brain
rather than anything
to do with suture
closure and timing thereof
of the skull. And it
often results in mental
deficiency because
it's the brain tissue
that's being affected.
And then finally, we
have hydrocephalus,
which is caused by
elevated pressure in
the brain ventricles
due to excess cerebral
spinal fluid buildup.
So this results
in larger brains, which
then pushes against
the skull during
skull development. So
this leads to this
expanded brain case
morphology. And this
is pretty common, which
occurs in one in
about thousand births.
And finally, in
this part, I'm going
to be talking
about pituitary and
their amazing
developmental origins.
So the pituitary,
also known as
hypothesis, is a
master endocrine gland.
And this is especially
true for growth and
reproduction. And the
anterior and posterior
lobes produce different
sets of hormones,
which you can see here,
but this is not going
to be tested, at
least for this lecture
content. So don't worry
about this for now.
But what's interesting
and what you will
get tested on is the
developmental or embryonic
origins of anterior
versus the posterior
lobe or the pituitary.
And I think it's
very neat. So what
happens is that the
anterior lobe forms
from the upgrowth of the
roof of the mouth,
which you can see here.
And this is called
the hypophysiopouch.
And then the posterior
lobe comes from
above, from the
downgrowth of the floor of
the embryonic brain,
the diencephalon.
And the brain is
originally from ectoderm.
So they're both
ectodermal in their
origins, but obviously
they're coming from
totally different
parts or tissues, which
is remarkable. And the
anterior and posterior
lobes of the the
pituitary, while
these pouches kind
of dance together and
come together to eventually
form the anterior
and posterior lobes
of the pituitary.
This is part
three of the FOM
lecture on head and
neck embryology.
In this last section,
we're going to be
talking about germ
layer contributions
to various head and
neck structures.
So there are three
major germ layers in the
body. So these are
ectoderm, mesoderm, and
endoderm, same as other
parts of the body.
And in the ectoderm, in
addition to
the epidermis,
the ectoderm leads
to the creation of
the brain and the
cranial nerves. And
these are because
it is derived from
this neural tube, which
is going to become
both the brain and
the spinal cord.
You also have placodes
that are derived from
ectoderm, as we talked
about in the previous
part of the lecture.
And these are
associated with some of
the special senses in
the head and neck,
including the eye lens,
vestidial and
cochlea in the
inner ear and
nasal cavity.
And ectoderm is
also responsible
for generating
parotid gland.
Moving on to the
mesoderm, as expected,
these form the bones and
cartilaginous tissues,
arteries, and muscles.
And in the head,
a lot of these are
coming from pharyngeal
structures. Remember
the pharyngeal arches.
And the funny thing
about in the head is
that these mesodermal
tissues will interact
with what's called
neocrest cells, which
we'll be talking
about in the next
section. But neocrest
cells are ectodermally
derived, a very special
set of cells that
can kind of go from
ectoderm into cell
populations that kind
of act like mesoderm.
And then you also have
the skull, which is
part of the bone and
cartilaginous tissues
in the head. So
that's derived from
mesoderm as well. And
then endoderm, you have
the glandular tissues,
except for the
parotid gland, and then
the mucosae around the
oral and the nasal
cavities and beyond.
so i promise that
i'll be talking about
neurocrest cells so
neurocrest cells are
populations of cells
that originate in
the neural fold so
recall in earlier
embryonic lectures
that you have an
ectodermal layer in very
early embryonic stage
and the ectodermal
layer is going to
invaginate and then
is going to split off
and that split off part
is going to form a tube
and called neurotube
and this is what's
going to become the
brain and the spinal cord
and what you're
also left with
is this continuous
ectodermal
layer which is
going to later
produce the epidermis
but then during this
invagination process
there's a region
that's folded. And
this is called a neural
fold. And from there
emerges these very
special populations
of multi-potent cells
called neurocrest
cells. And neurocrest
cells are, again,
ectodermally derived,
but forms secondary
mesenchyme. So these
are mesoderm-like
structures. They act
like although they
came out of ectoderm.
And these neurocrest
cells migrate all
over the body to
turn into a wonderful
array of different
tissues. So these
include cartilage
and bone, teeth,
skin, melanocytes,
smooth muscles,
glands, adipose
tissue, neurons, glia,
adrenal medulla,
et cetera. And it's
responsible for most
of the connective and
the skeletal tissue
of the head, nerves,
and pigment cells.
And here are the
derivatives of the
neurocrest cells in
the head and neck
in all its glory.
So in terms of
cartilage and bone,
it forms most of
the bones and
cartilage in the head.
So these include
the facial bones,
which are listed
here, as well
as some in the
cranial base,
including parts of
the sphenoid bone.
And it also forms
all three of
the middle your
ossicles, the
malleus, incus,
and stapes,
hyoid, and the
laryngeal cartilage.
So these are all
cartilage and bony
structures that
are derived from
pharyngeal arches
from part one of this
lecture on head and
neck embryology.
In the same way, for
the nervous system
derivatives, it includes
sensory ganglia of
cranial nerve 5, 7,
9, and 10, which are
branchiomeric nerves. So
these are cranial nerves
that are associated
with pharyngeal arches.
And it also includes
their peripheral nerves.
And for the muscles,
so the neocrest cells
do not directly become
muscles, but they
interact with the
mesoderms in the
pharyngeal arches to
form the muscles of the
head and neck, including
the jaw muscles.
And then there
are other key
structures that
come from neocrest
cells. So these
include teeth,
particularly the dentine
component of it,
but not enamel.
It also forms dermis
and hyperdermis of the
face and the neck,
creates the choroid and
sclera of the eye,
and melanocytes in the
iris, as well as the
rest of the body. So if
you think that someone's
eyes and their eye
color is beautiful, you
can thank neurocrest
cells. And it's also
responsible for developing
meninges and connective
tissues of lacrimal
salivary and thymus
clads not the glandular
tissues themselves
but the connective
tissues surrounding
them and now what's
interesting is so neurocrest
cells have all these
different kinds of
derivatives so there have
been a lot of research
on why we have so
many dog breeds and one
of the secrets could
be related to neurocrest
cells and that's
been demonstrated for
some of the attributes.
So for example, if you
look across different
dog breeds, you definitely
see quite different
and varying skull
shapes. For example,
looking at husky skill
and chihuahua skull.
And then obviously
dog breeds are
known for the
differences in fur color.
And what is the cause
or what are responsible
for some of these
traits? Well, it all
goes back to neurocrest
cells. So there
must've been
artificial selection on
neurocrest cells that
produced all these
coordinated changes very
quickly historically.
Now, we're going
to end it talking
about clinical
correlates related to
neurocrest cells.
And so one of them
is called Treacher
-Collins syndrome,
and it's caused by
genetic disorder that
involves faulty
migration of neurocrest
cells in the head
in the pharyngeal
arches one and two
and occurs about one
in 50,000 births.
And so the symptoms
or the syndrome
includes hearing loss,
downturned eyes,
underdevelopment
of the midface,
micronathia or a small
lower jaw and cleft
palate. So these
are all coordinated
traits that neurocrest
cell controls, especially
the development of
the facial bones.
So Treacher-Collin
syndrome is the result
of faulty migration
of neurocrest cells.
So let's end it with
an example question.
So a six-year-old
girl exhibits a
swelling in the anterior
part of her neck,
just inferior to the
thyroid bone. Which
of the following may
explain a swelling?
So in this question,
think about
the location of
the opening. Is
it on the midline
of the neck or
the lateral aspect
of the neck? So
the answer is C, which
is associated with the
thyroglossal duct cyst.
So if the swelling
or opening was
associated with the
lateral part of the
neck, then it would
have been the intact
cervical sinus.
And the obliteration
of the cervical
sinus, which is answer
B, which this is just
part of normal
development. So this
would not lead to any
particular swelling.
And then obliteration
of thytoglossal
ducts, similarly is
what happens under
typical development.
And then incomplete
closure of
secondary palate is
something that would
cause cleft palate.
So a totally different
kind of condition.
So together with the
previous lecture on
introduction to the
head and neck, I hope
I've convinced you
that the head and
the neck that supports
it is a truly special
and wonderfully
complex region. I know
it's a difficult
and very complicated
area of the body,
but I also hope that
you enjoy and appreciate
this complexity.
So just to finish
up this lecture,
These are the
topics that I
recommend you
focusing on in
your preparation
for the exams.
So first, make
sure you know the
derivatives of the
pharyngeal arches, pouches,
clefts, and
membranes. So complete
that table and study
off of that table.
Development of the
face, skull, palate,
tongue, thyroid
gland, placos,
and the pituitary
gland. Make sure you
understand the
process involved in
the development of
these structures.
And then the germ layer
and the neurocrestal
origins of the head
and neck structures.
And then, of
course, the clinical
implications
that arise from
abnormalities in head
and neck development
that I covered
in the lectures.
This is the end
of the FOM lecture
on the head and
neck embryology.
And I'd be grateful
if you can provide
any feedback on my
lectures, which you
can do by clicking
in the hyperlink in
the PowerPoint files.
And if you have
any questions about
the lecture content,
please do not
hesitate to email me.
The email address
is down here.
Thank you for
listening and
hope you have a
wonderful day.